an aviation detachment in Vung Tau is
conducting an experimental program the
mission is to evaluate three ch-47
Chinook helicopters that have been armed
and armoured there's nothing
half-hearted about the way these
choppers are armed each one carries 5 50
caliber machine gun to 20 millimeter
guns are mounted externally on pylons
and just below them to rocket pods
firing 2.75 rockets finally there's a
40-millimeter grenade launcher in the
aircraft's nose the arm Chinooks are
experimental but no one is resorting to
proving ground techniques and trying
them out not when there are actual known
enemy positions handy in the nearby
jungle the Chinooks are being used in
securing landing areas knocking out
enemy ground fire and soft targets much
of this activity has been in support of
the Royal Australian task force today's
mission to is to assist the offi there
are known Vietcong positions around the
Australian base camp the mission is
plain and simple clear out the Vietcong
troops in the area the arm Chinook
you
in the designation ch-47 a the CH stands
for cargo helicopter in the case of
these flying arsenals it might well be
altered to combat helicopter
the outfit calls itself guns agogo and
for good and obvious reasons after the
strike the helicopters land at position
kangaroo in the Royal Australian task
force area here the Flyers discuss the
results of the mission with our allies
from Down Under some of the men take the
opportunity to work on a 20-millimeter
cannon that's been giving trouble then
later back again for another strike the
weather has closed in somewhat but it
takes more than clouds to ground this
detachment the assignment is evaluate
the armed choppers and there are
perfectly good Vietcong positions down
there to evaluate the lawn
our own findings on the arm Chinooks are
not yet complete but the VC maybe doing
some evaluating to if so it's a pretty
fair bet that they've already concluded
the arm ch-47 a is mighty effective
the men of the 100 first airborne are
sometimes called the nomads of Vietnam
and here one of their supporting units
finds itself really living the nomadic
life it only looks like a Bedouin
encampment in the Sahara actually it's a
base camp in vball where an aviation
battalion is weathering a wind and sand
storm but wind or not business goes on
at a nearby beach and LST brings in
helicopter maintenance parts the
aviation unit has been supporting the
one hundred and first division and arvin
troops throughout the at nam and that
adds up to a lot of wear and tear on the
choppers replacement parts run in size
all the way up to new rotor blades
today's mission involves airlifting
Vietnamese troops for a jungle assault
on the enemy the wind has abated and the
men stand ready right on schedule the
Huey's arrived to pick up their
passengers
the armed escort gets some new teeth
the electrical firing devices are set on
the gunships rockets and the Arvin's
board the helicopters and soldierly
fashion ready for battle weather wind
and sand have failed to interfere the
airlift gets underway around the landing
zone enemy positions are taken for
granted and accordingly are promptly
taken care of
still right on schedule the Vietnamese
troops unload at the landing zone
helicopters continue to prove their
value in operations in South Vietnam
10 kilometers north of play cool a
chinook helicopter has crashed while
supporting a combat field operation
recovery of this aircraft begins as
another ch-47 writes the fuselage so
mechanics will be able to dismantle its
engines the date is July 27 all wreckage
from the downed helicopter is to be
removed and returned to the maintenance
area at unque members of the recovery
team begin removing the heavier parts to
lighten the fuselage for later air left
the task of dismantling the aircraft is
made particularly difficult because of
damage to the parts engine parts are
taken to a waiting car go helicopter and
loaded aboard as items of freight for
this recovery operation ten men have
been dispatched to the scene of the
crash some of the men begin gathering up
the scattered pieces of wreckage and
loading them aboard the waiting Chinook
meanwhile another cargo helicopter is
busy removing the rear transmission by
means of sling load before the day is
over there won't be a trace left of the
crash finally a CH 54 flying crane
appears and starts to pick up the strip
fuselage of a Chinook here again the
load is handled by sling lip as a huge
chopper begins to rise vertically a
ribbon parachute is deployed to
stabilize the ponderous load in flight
then the flying crane climbs ever higher
over the mountains the long airlift
nears its end as the flying crane begins
descending toward the maintenance area
at on K
the wreck Chinook is expertly eased into
position near the base repair facility
the hook up is released and the mission
is completed in another type of
helicopter support and artillery unit of
the Royal Australian Army is aided in
moving a field piece located at netsuite
32 kilometers east of vung tau this
battery is moving its guns from one
location to another in the field the US
Army helicopter is from a base in buntao
with the artillery weapons sling loaded
the American helicopter quickly hauls it
away whisking it over the treetops as
the Aussies watch it go
the gun arrives at the new battery site
a few kilometers away in a matter of
moments as the Chinook sails away toward
vongtau the Australians take over and
ready the gun for action at tiny narrow
strip 88 kilometers northwest of Saigon
a shipment of radio communications
equipment is loaded aboard a Huey the
shipment is bound for New ebaugh 10 the
black virgin mountain where a special
forces radio relay site is situated 16
kilometres from tiny the summit where
the American outpost is located is the
highest point in the third core area but
today visibility is poor despite the
low-hanging clouds however the chopper
goes in to deliver the badly needed
radio equipment the rest of this
mountain below the summit is controlled
by the enemy the men of the Special
Forces camp immediately unload the new
equipment these people must be supplied
by air almost daily so they can continue
to hold the strategic mountaintop and
maintain line-of-sight radio
transmission service mission completed
the Huey takes off from this 3,200 foot
helipad to continue its duties perhaps
the most vital function of the
helicopter in Vietnam is the aerial
resupply of troops in the field here at
the camp Holloway army airfield at
pleiku choppers are loaded with rations
and water for troops of the 25th
infantry division during combat
operation Paul Revere several kilometres
to the north these aerial resupply
deliveries are often the only means of
keeping the troops applied during jungle
operations this means flying deep into
enemy territory and the air crew is
constantly on the alert the weapons
platoon receiving the supplies
is located about 12 kilometers from the
Cambodian border and is badly in need of
this delivery no sooner does the chopper
touchdown then the hasty business of
unloading begins with fresh food water
and ammunition these infantryman are now
able to carry the operation to a
successful conclusion
to the familiar strains of when the
saints go marching in elements of the
2nd Brigade 4th infantry division
arrived in vietnam on 7 August led by
commanding officer Colonel Judson H
Miller the first contingent of troops
march ashore past the Korean tiger
division ban the 4th division is most
famous for its d-day landing on Utah
Beach during World War two rows of
welcoming Vietnamese women wait to
shower the men with Garland's of flowers
on hand for the occasion is Army Chief
of Staff General Harold k johnson and
commanding general william c
Westmoreland who officially greets the
truth Colonel Miller officers and men of
the 4th division I welcome you to
Vietnam the Vietnamese were fighting for
the same rights and freedom that we in
the United States fought for and 1776 in
this struggle we are joined by many of
our allies as soldiers of the United
States Army will fight side by side with
members of the armed forces of Vietnam
Korea Australia and New Zealand
the peoples of many other nations are
watching what we do here by your
presence in Vietnam you will represent
not only the United States Army but also
the American people after the generals
address the Granada troops board buses
for Keaney on Air Base where they will
be airlifted to play cool the arrival of
the 2nd Brigade brings American forces
in Vietnam to an all-time high
10 augis a farewell review in honor of
the three-member mediation committee
sent to the strife-torn dominican
republic by the Organization of American
States the commander of the
inter-american police force Brazil's
general Alvaro braha arrives at the
ceremony is accompanied by ellsworth
bunker US ambassador to OAS they are
treated by Brigadier General Robert R
Linville commander US forces Dominican
Republic
ambassador bunker and the two generals
inspect truth elements from the
inter-american force
later general braha presents each of the
committee members with a certificate of
achievement marking completion of their
assignment ilmar penny marine [ __ ]
brazil ambassador bunkers and ramon de
clermont dwayne us of el salvador on
behalf of the committee ambassador
bunker express appreciation for the
honors bestowed on them soldiers from
the Americas person review before the
committee members the parade includes
troops from Honduras Nicaragua and
Brazil as well as from the United States
helicopters of the u.s. 280 3rd army
aviation company staged a flyby with
each chopper trailing colored smoke a
precision skydiving event by members of
the US army parachute team winds up the
ceremonies each member of the committee
is presented with an engraved relay
stick a symbolic memento of the fine
teamwork that has characterized inter
American operations in the Dominican
Republic
tonight the first group of men are
returning to Vietnam at five days in R&R
here in Hawaii Master Sergeant Charles
Meadows is the ncoic of the rnr Center
soy medals can you tell me how the first
group of men took to Hawaii on their
first trip here from all indications
talking with several of the men they
enjoyed herself very much and said they
would recommend it to their fellow men
in Vietnam whenever game certain metals
how have you found local support for
this local support was 100% the people
contended the other way possible by
cutting the race on her hotels the shows
and different things in they support at
one hundred percent ok thank you sgt oh
this is sergeant first class raymond
Faludi and his family Sarn Flutie is
from Hawaii presently he is stationed in
Vietnam with the 50 second aviation
battalion had been long son Flutie what
did you do during your time here in
Hawaii and my wife around visit our
relatives away in the island we also
take advantage of that are in our card
with a faceted eyes when we arrival we
are in Honolulu a light which I want to
thank everybody governor burns and more
sharp all official make this trip
success start including when you return
to your unit do you plan to recommend
Hawaii to the men personally recommend i
think this is one of the most and a
wonderful opportunity for every man in
Vietnam
mrs. Ballew t what did you think of your
husbands are in our trip here to Hawaii
well I thought it was wonderful that he
could come home after day in the right
level month and we all miss him and was
true glad to see him this is sergeant
Emmett Higgins of advisory team 87 in
Vietnam he is at present and advisor
with the Vietnamese 10th infantry
division sergeant higgins how did you
find your reception here in Hawaii well
I don't worry over one else expected
such a thing I did not and I enjoyed the
people meeting this and I was just
overwhelmed with many people out to see
us sign did you have much of a chance to
use the facilities here at Port de rusia
yesterday that I used all the facilities
in the PX the laundry and all the
services here and I want to really
express myself to the people are really
sure showed us around the area here mrs.
cburg and
vivaro and myself the other two air
force man really had a lovely time with
the people and also I'd like to impress
this up to the Navy who is a nuclear sub
over here who took me to kentucky fried
chicken dinner yesterday so you come
back again if you had i will and i hope
back a couple months okay thanks a lot
size as the owl report departure draws
near the R&R a personnel returning to
vietnam are debriefed in the fourth
debussy auditorium they are asked to
fill out forms commenting on their visit
to hawaii heading for their airport
buses the troops are entertained one
last time while the music and dances of
Polynesia
dependence of the returnees have time
for one last Aloha a roster check is
made at each man boards the bus for
Hickam Air Force Base the wonderful
holiday is over and many hearts were
heavy in these final moments of farewell
then the big army buses roll and the rnr
troops say aloha hawaii as they returned
to the war against the viet cong
you
you